el expresidente Mauricio Funes recibió
de parte de un tribunal capitalino una
sentencia de 14 años de prisión por los
delitos de agrupaciones ilícitas e
incumplimiento de deberes el exministro
de justicia y seguridad pública David
Munguía payés fue condenado también a 18
años de cárcel por dichos delitos Además
del de actos arbitrarios Funes y Munguía
palés Fueron acusados por la fiscalía de
avalar en el 2012 las negociaciones
entre las pandillas para acordar una
supuesta reducción de los homicidios a
cambio de beneficios para los cabecillas
de la Mara Salvatrucha y el barrio 18
que se encontraban recluidos en centros
penitenciarios durante su gestión entre
ellos el traslado a centros penales de
menor seguridad y reuniones con otros
miembros de la estructura que estaban
fuera de las cárceles la representación
fiscal se mostró satisfecha con el fallo
del caso tregua y lo considero considero
de histórico por tratarse de un
expresidente de la República Funes
estuvo en la presidencia entre 2009 y
2014 actualmente vive en Nicaragua tras
haber obtenido la nacionalidad de ese
país en cambio Munguía país se encuentra
en prisión debido a estas acusaciones
ambos funcionarios han negado
reiteradamente los cargos que se le
imputan Y esperan que o esperan que
presenten una apelación a la resolución
del juez una publicación del periódico
digital El Faro de 2020 sugiere que
también el actual gobierno del
presidente bukele sostuvo negociaciones
con las principales pandillas del país
dentro de penales de máxima seguridad a
fin de mantener el histórico desplome
del número de homicidios reportado en su
gestión sin embargo hasta ahora no se
conoce si existe una línea de
investigación al respecto por parte de
la fiscalía